So I'm not depressed
now.
But I was depressed for a long time, and I wrote about
being depressed, and
I lived for a long time with blinding depression, and
had long stretches when everything seemed hopeless
and pointless. When returning calls from friends seemed like more than I could do.
When getting up and going out into the world seemed painful. When
I was completely crippled with
anxiety. And when I finally got better and started writing
about the process of recovery, I became very interested in all of the different
kinds of treatment that there were for depression.
And having started as a kind of medical conservative; thinking that there were only a couple of things
that worked -- medication, and certain talking therapies, and that that was really it -- I
very gradually began to change my mind, because I realized
that if you have brain cancer and you decide that standing on your head and
gargling for half an hour every day makes you feel better, it may make you feel better, but the likelihood is
that you still have brain cancer, and you're still going to die from it. But if you have depression,
and you say that standing on your head and gargling for half an hour makes you feel better,
then you are actually cured. Because depression is an
illness of how you feel, and if you feel really great after you do that, then you're
not depressed anymore. But I began to think all kinds of things could work, and
I researched everything ranging from experimental brain surgeries
to hypnotic regimens of various kinds. I had people
writing to me because I had been publishing on this
subject. There was one woman who wrote to me and she said that she had tried actually.
electroshock treatments and a variety of other approaches to depression --
medication and therapy -- and she had finally found the thing that worked for her, and she
wanted me to tell the world about it. And that was making little things from yarn.
Some of which she sent
me, and none of which I'm wearing
right now. But in any event. Um, I had that,
um, that rich engagement. And I also became interested, as I was doing this work, in the idea
that depression existed not only in the civilized west, as people
tended to perceive it to exist, but
actually across cultures, and had existed across time.
And so when one of my dearest friends,
my friend David Hecht, who was living for a little while in Senegal, said to me, "Do you
know about the tribal rituals that are used for the treatment of depression here?"
I said, "No I don't know about them, but I would like to know about them." And he said, "Well if
you come for a visit, we could try to do some research on this topic."
And so I set off for Senegal. And I met David. And I was
introduced to David's then-girlfriend, now ex-wife,
Hélène. And it turned out
that Hélène had a cousin whose mother was a friend
of someone who went
to school with the daughter of a person who actually practiced the Undop.
And that I could therefore go and interview this woman who had practiced the undop.
And so we went off, um, to a small town about two hours outside of
Dakar,
and I was introduced to this extraordinary,
old, large woman wrapped in miles and
miles of African fabric printed with figures of eyes. And she
was Madame Diouf. And we did an interview for about an hour, and she told me all about the ndeup.
And the end of it, feeling rather daring, I said, "Listen," I said, "I hope...
I don't know whether this is something you would even consider," I said, "But would it be possible for me to attend
an undop?" And she said,
"Well, I certainly never had a foreigner (the local word was toubab) I've never had a
foreigner attend one of these before," she said, "but
actually," she said, "I mean, you've come through these friends and these connections," she said. "Yes. The
next time I perform an ndeup, you may be present." And I said, "That's fantastic!" I said,
"When are you next going to be doing an ndeup?"
And she said, "Oh, it'll be sometime in the next six months."
And I said, "Six months is quite a long time for me to stay here in this town,
waiting for you to do one." I said, "Is there anyone who might... maybe you could expedite one
for somebody? Move it forward? I'll pitch in."
And she said, "No, it
really doesn't work that way." She said, "I'm sorry but that's how
it is."
And I said, "Well, I guess I won't be able to see an ndeup then, but even so, this conversation has
been so interesting and so helpful to me, and I'm, I'm a
little sad leaving here about not actually getting to see one, but I thank you."
And she said, "Well, I'm glad that you could come. I'm glad it was helpful." And she said, "But there is
one other thing." She said, "I hope you don't mind my saying this..." And I said,
"No, what? What is it?"And she said, "You don't look that
great yourself." She said, "Are you... you are suffering
from depression?" And I said, "Well, yes," I said, "it
was very acute, it's kind of a little better now, but, yeah, I still do actually
suffer from depression." She said, "Well, I've certainly never done this for a toubab
before, but I could actually do an ndeup for you."
And I said, "Oh!" I said, "What an interesting idea!" I said,
"Well, yes, uh, sure. Yeah, absolutely yes,
let's, let's, let's do
that, then I'll have an ndeup." And she said, "Oh well, that's great," she
said, and she gave us some sort of fairly basic instructions, and then
we left, and my translator -- the aforementioned then-
girlfriend now ex-wife of my friend --
turned to me and she said, "Are you completely crazy? Do you have any idea
what you're getting yourself into?" And I said, "Well, you know, I mean, all these things
are very interesting." She said, "You're crazy!" She said, "You're totally crazy, but I'll help you if you want."
So we had left, and the first thing we had was a shopping list. There had been... you could get
them to buy the stuff, but you had to pay a surcharge. I said no, we'd buy the stuff, so we had to go out,
we had to buy seven
yards of African fabric.
We had to get a calabash,
which was a large bowl fashioned from a gourd. We had to get three
kilos of millet. We had to get sugar. We had to get Kola beans. And then we
had to get two live cockerels, two roosters, and a
ram. And so Hélène and I went to the market with David
and with these other people, and we got most of the things, and I said, "Well, but what, what
about the the ram?" And Hélène said, "We can't buy the ram today; what are we going to
do with it overnight?" So I saw the sense of that. So the next
day, [Laughter]
the next day we got into a taxi to go back out
two hours to where we were going. And I said, "What about the ram?"And Hélène said, "Oh, we'll see
a ram along the
way." We were going along and going along,
and there was a Senegalese shepherd by the side of the road with his flock, and we stopped
the cab and we got out, and we
bought the ram for seven dollars. And then we had a little bit of a
struggle getting the live ram into the trunk of the taxicab. So.
But the cab driver seemed not at all worried, even by the fact that the ram kept relieving himself.
in the trunk of the taxicab.
And so then, we got to Rufisque, and we got there. So here I am, I'm
ready for my close up. And the thing about the ndeup is that it
varies enormously depending on a whole variety of signals and symbols that come
from above, so we had to go through this
whole shamanistic process, and I still didn't know really very much of what
was going to happen. So first I had to change out of my jeans my T-shirt and put on
a loincloth.
And then I sat down. And then I had my chest and my arms rubbed with millett
and then -- which is a grain -- and then someone said, "Oh, we really should
have music, um, for this," and I said, "Oh great!" And I thought, you know, drumming, I thought some
atmospheric thing. And she came out with her very prized possession, which was a battery operated
tape player, for which she had one tape, which was Chariots of Fire.
So we started listening to Chariots of
Fire, and in the meanwhile I was given, sort of,
various shamanistic objects. I had to hold with my hands and drop them. I had to hold them with my feet and drop
them. They would sort of say, "Oh, this augurs well, this augurs badly" -- there were five assistants to Madame Dopif
who had all gathered
around. And we sort of spent the morning like this, and it was all really just fine, and then
they said, it was maybe, we'd start at about eight, maybe about eleven, eleven-thirty, they said, "Well
now it's actually time for the central part of the ritual," and I said,
"Okay." And the sound of drumming began -- the drumming I'd been hoping for -- the drumming began.
And so there was all of this drumming. And it was very exciting, and we went to
the central square of the village where there was a small,
makeshift wedding bed that I had to get into with the
ram.
And I had been told it would be very very bad luck if the ram escaped. And I had to hold on
to him. And that the reason we had to be in this wedding bed was that all my depression and all my
problems were caused by the fact that I had spirits. In Senegal, you have spirits sort
of
all over you the way here you sort of have microbes: some are good for you, some are bad for you, some are neutral. Anyway,
my bad spirits were extremely jealous of my real life,
sexual partners. Some of whom are here
tonight. And, um, [laughter] uh, that we had to
mollify
the anger of the spirits. So I had to get into this wedding bed with the ram,
and I had to hold the ram very tightly. Because he, he was not having a good life,
this ram. And he, of course, immediately relieved himself on my
leg. And the entire village had taken the day off from their work in
the fields and were dancing around in concentric circles. And as they danced,
throwing blankets and sheets of cloth over us. And so we were gradually being buried, and it
was unbelievably hot, and it was completely stifling,
and there was the sound of the stamping feet as everyone danced around us, and then these drums were getting
louder and louder and more ecstatic and more ecstatic, and I was just about at the point which I thought
I was going to faint or pass out. At
that key moment. Suddenly all of the cloths were pulled off.
I was yanked to my feet, the loincloth that was all I was wearing was pulled from me,
the poor old ram's throat was slit, as were the throats of the two cockerels, and
I was covered in the blood of the freshly slaughtered ram and the cockerels.
And so there I was naked, totally covered in blood. And they said,
"Okay, that's the end of this part of
it," and I said, "Well, OK." And they
said, "But, uh, you," they said
we're,
actually, we, but there's the next piece comes now." And I said, "OK." And we went over back to the area where we had done
the morning preparations. And one of them said, "But look, it's kind of lunch time, why don't we just take a break
for a minute.
Would you like a Coke?"
I don't drink Coke that much, but at that moment it seems like a really, really, really good idea and I
said, "Yes." And so I sat there, naked and completely covered in animal blood,
with Flies kind of gathering, as they will when you're naked in covered in animal blood, and
I drank this Coke. And then when I had finished the Coke, they said, "Okay, now we
have decided the sort of final parts of
the ritual." They said, "So first you have to put your hands by your sides
and hold your, stand very straight and very erect." And I said,
"OK." And then they tied me up with the intestines of the ram.
And in the meanwhile it was hanging from a nearby tree and they were... there were some people doing some
butchering of it. And they took various little bits of it out. And then I had to kind of
shuffle over, all tied up in Intestines. Which most of you probably
haven't done but it's hard.
I had to
shuffle over, and I had to take these little pieces of the ram, and I had to
dig holes. And I had to put the pieces of the ram
in the holes. And I had to say something. But what I had to say was actually, to me,
incredibly, strangely touching in the middle of
this weird experience. I had to say, "Spirits,
leave me alone to complete the business of my life, and
know that I will never forget you." And I thought, "What a kind thing
to say to the evil spirits you're exorcising, and that, 'I'll never forget you.'" and I
haven't. So, anyway, there were various other little bits and pieces that followed. I was given
a piece of paper in which all of the millet from the morning had been gathered. I was
told that the next morning, I should sleep with it under my pillow and in the morning get
up and give it to a beggar who had good hearing and no deformities. And that when I gave it to him,
that would be the end of my troubles. And then the women, sort of all filled
their mouths with water and began spitting water all over me, which it turns out is the
sort of -- it's the surround shower
effect. And rinsing
the blood away from me, and it gradually came off. And when I was clean they gave me back
my jeans, and everyone danced and they barbecued the ram, and we had
this dinner, and I felt so
up! I felt so up. It had, It
had been quite
an astonishing experience. Even though I didn't believe in the animist principles behind it,
all of these people had been gathered together cheering for me, and it was
very exhilarating.
And I had a very odd experience, five years later, when I was working on my current book.
and I was in Rwanda doing something else altogether, and I got into a conversation with someone there,
And I described the experience I've had in Senegal. And he said, "Oh, you know, we have something that's
a little like that." He said, "That's west Africa this is east Africa; it's quite different. But.
there are some similarities in some rituals here." He said, "You know, we had a lot of trouble with Western
mental health workers who came here immediately after the genocide. And we have to ask some of them to leave."
And I said, "What, what was the problem?"And he said, "Okay, they came, and
their practice did not involve being outside in the sun, like what you're describing, which is after
all where do you begin to feel better. There was no music or drumming to get your blood flowing
again when you're depressed and you're low and you need to have your blood flowing."
He said, "There was no sense that everyone had taken the day off so that the entire community
could come together to try to lift you up and bring you back to Joy."
He said, "There was no acknowledgment of the depression as something invasive and external that could
actually be cast out of you again." He said, "Instead, they would take people one at
a time into these dingy little
rooms, and have them sit around for an hour or so and talk about bad things that had happened
to them."
He
said, "We had to get them to leave the country." [Laughter] Thank
you.
[Applause]